in 2015 goodnight Mommy a woman returns
to her isolated home after surgery where
twin Sons greet her at least they
believe she's her mother but her angry
often violent reactions to them cause
the boys to suspect otherwise they hold
her cup dip in increasingly cruel ways
to extract a confession from her but
what they eventually discover is far
more complicated and chilling than a
simple imposter situation adding
considerably to the creepiness of this
Austrian film is that two young boys
play the twins Elias and Lucas Schwartz
who according to various sources were 12
while filming carry out many unsettling
acts they raise huge cockroaches and
look after a dead cat and eventually tie
down and seal their alleged mother's
mouth shut to prevent her from screaming
for help when she refuses to change her
story The Boy's clue her to the floor
and said the house of Lace by that point
it's far too late for anyone to change
their story